you don't  food the lru a fine display of gratitude  I'm no enemy if that's what you fear I  fear nothing my name is Evelyn I seek  the leader of these men he calls himself  lost one mac on that you seek him to  attend a final one ah then you are my  kind of woman names Gucci Oh Maya  partner in crime is Elise though I've  heard her called otherwise will you help  me find their base no one knows these  waters as you do in return I'll restore  your control of this territory I've  built we've invested years of work in  this cabin why would we need your help  aw reasons right there would you not  prefer to move your where it's free d if  you think there's only one base you  really do need me those louts are spread  out in a swamp gas it's setter then  Elise will help you find the blighters  you